MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this section, we
talk about calorimetry.
In contrast to the discussion
of tracking detectors,
here what we're trying
to do is measure
the energy of the particles.
And we do this by
basically destroying them.
The underlying content is
rather straightforward.
We have a particle.
And we put a piece of
material in front of it,
such that it slams
into it, and the energy
deposited by the particle is
the energy, the measurement
we try to undertake.
So in nuclear and
particle physics,
that is exactly what we
refer to as calorimetrics.
So the detection of particles
for measuring the properties
through the total absorption
in the block of matter.
The common feature, or
the central feature,
is that the measurement
is destructive.
So again, in tracking
detectors, we
try to minimally
disturb the particle
and in calorimetrics,
we try to destroy them.
The exception to this
might be a muon which
might at high energies
deposit only a small fraction
of its energy in
the calorimeter,
or a neutrino, which
just flies through
without having any interaction.
But the purpose is really
to measure energies
by destroying the particle.
And it's widely used in all
kinds of areas of particle
and nuclear physics.
Neutrino experiments, proton
decay experiments, cosmic ray
detectors, collider
experiments, and so on.
And in collider experiments
specifically, the idea
is to build the detector such
that it completely surrounds
the interaction region, such
that you don't lose energy
from the collision just passing
through an uninstrumented
region.
The detection mechanism
can vary quite a bit.
We use scintillators a lot.
We use silicon in
some modern detectors.
With ionization, we use
Cherenkov detection.
We use sometimes
cryogenic detectors,
which are very sensitive to
very small energy depositions,
and they can be quite useful.
They are used in dark
matter experiments
or on neutrino [INAUDIBLE]
decay experiments like so.
Again, conceptually,
you can differentiate
between homogeneous
calorimetrics and sampling
calorimeters.
The homogeneous calorimeters,
basically the entire absorbable
material is equal or is the
same as the detector material.
So an example for this is lead
glass, which is often used.
So what you do then
in the calorimeter
is you induce electromagnetic
and nuclear showers
and then the energy
of the incoming party
is converted into photons.
And then what you need
is a photodetector,
which then measures the
number of photons coming out
of your detector material.
For this to work, the detector
needs to be transparent.
Alternatively, one can
use sampling experiment,
sampling detectors, where you
have the heavy material being
used in order to induce a shower
and then the detection material
in order to count, again,
the number of photons.
So homogeneous calorimeter
have typically very good energy
resolution.
And the reason for this
is that nothing gets lost.
Everything is being measured
in the absorber, which
is the detector.
But that leads then
to some limitations.
For example, that the
granularity of the detector
is typically limited.
And then there's no
longitudinal information
about the shower development.
You basically have one block.
For example, a left
blockage is shown here,
the tungsten block,
which is shown here,
are used for the measurement.
So you produce photons,
and so then the photons
need to be measured.
And then that's done
with photodetectors.
Here, the requirements,
the range of requirements,
is quite big.
Sometimes you want to be able
to measure every single photon
so the quantum efficiency
needs to be quite high.
In other detectors,
you need to be
able to put this detector in
a radiation hot environment.
And so that then changes.
The main types available are the
old-fashioned photomultiplier
tubes, which actually become
quite sophisticated, PMTs.
There's gas-based
photodetectors.
There's solid-state detectors,
which are quite popular,
so-called SIPM
silicon photodetectors
or some hybrid modules of those.
So the energy resolution
in a calorimeter
depends on a number of things.
As I was saying, one measures
the number of particles
being produced in a shower.
And so that's just a
counting experiment.
And the uncertainty
of that scales
to the square root of
the number of particles
produced or measured.
And so here, we have
a square root n term.
So the relative
energy measurement
has an arrow, which is with 1
over square root of the energy.
And then there's
more contributions.
There's constant terms, which
come from inhomogeneities.
Those are elements
where there's just
no detector, no equipment in
the direction of the party.
But those can be overlapped
regions or regions
where you have two detector
modules being glued together.
You don't measure there.
And that leads to them, a
constant term in the energy
resolution.
And then when you
translate the signal,
the electromagnetic signals
into an electronic signal,
there can be noise induced,
and that noise then
leads to a typical turn, which
goes with one over the energy.
So very classical, you
have those three components
to the energy--
three components to
the energy resolution.
One is this 1 over the
square root of the energy.
One is constant, and one is
depending on 1 over the energy.
And so when you
design a detector,
you want to place it
such or design it such
that the most
important physics you
want to do with this
detector is optimize
towards those components.